did you know that there's a taco bell at
the pentagon technically we can no
longer confirm it but back before the
information got restricted there were
websites confirming that yep there was
in fact an entire food court there
complete with a subway a kfc dunkin
donuts and of course the bell gotta say
bold choice there u.s military bold
choice hope your toilets are as powerful
as your fighter jets anyway none of this
has anything to do with today's theory
it was just an interesting thing that i
learned while researching for it that i
wanted to pass along to you uh i have no
good transition here so uh throw up a
title card make it explode and hyper
masculine you know
hello internet welcome to film theory
talk to me goose so i got a confession
to make i do not like the original top
gun i know i know it is cinematic
blasphemy but the cocky hot shot
protagonist is just too unlikable the
treatment of women is too outdated and
overall everyone is just too darn sweaty
seriously it's like they jumped in a
pool before filming every scene someone
please get these men some towels the
only reason i'm telling you this is to
set context because despite my lowest of
low expectations i loved top gun
maverick this story of a few fighter
pilots trying to accomplish an
impossible mission had me at the edge of
my seat the entire time in a way that no
world ending sky beam ever has in the
last decade it was exciting but not
overdone it was simple but it wasn't
dumb and it was nostalgic but not like
annoying levels of nostalgic it was a
movie that was absolutely cheesy but it
recognized that fact and embraced the
cheese gotta say i just really really
liked it and apparently i'm not the only
one in a year that so far has featured
massive mcu crossovers the return of the
most popular superhero ever and the
conclusion to one of the 90s most
popular movie franchises the biggest
film story of 2022 has been top gun
maverick taking home the box office gold
crossing a billion dollars and crushing
absolutely all of the competition like
it's not even close but perhaps most
interesting of all is that it does all
of this without an identifiable bad guy
despite setting up this hugely important
and impossible mission from the word go
maverick never officially identifies the
hostile enemy nation that tom cruise and
company end up in aerial combat against
we never actually get to see the enemies
face and this is actually a tradition
with the franchise you see in the
original top gun they did the same thing
they never once identified who they're
supposed to be flying against sure most
audiences generally assume that the
enemy was soviet russia provided that
the cold war was still pretty hot in
1986 and the fighters are id'd as migs
aka jets manufactured by the russian
mikoyan and gorovic design bureau but in
reality according to the filmmakers
years later the intent was for the enemy
nation to be north korea yeah i was
surprised too apparently the only reason
this became less clear in the final film
was because the u.s state department was
trying to normalize relations with the
north korean government so they asked
top guns producers to make the bad guys
some unidentified hostiles flying some
made-up jets by the way that
relationship between the government and
hollywood yeah that's probably worth
some theories one day anyway in the
original top gun this didn't really make
all that much of a difference it was
only an issue at the beginning and the
end of the story the enemy nation was
just a minor bookend for a plot about
hotshots working with each other at
school in the new movie maverick though
this whole plot is built on an
impossible suicide mission to stop a
country from achieving nuclear power and
since this is a realistic-ish drama you
can't just cheat like a marvel movie and
make up a fake country so to keep the
enemy presence anonymous top gun
maverick keeps the terrain remote and
interchangeable it largely confines the
action to flight suits and cockpits and
it makes the mission at the center of
this whole thing covert on a need to
know basis only but here's the thing i
need to know and i think that there's
enough in here to figure it out while
most of the details are kept vague and
nothing is explicitly stated we do learn
a lot implicitly about this nation
during the course of the training and
final execution of the mission so i
wanted to see if we could figure this
thing out what is the rogue nation that
tom cruise the gang are fighting against
in top gun maverick honestly i walked
out of the theater thinking yet again
that was a thinly veiled reference to
russia spoiler alert it's not in fact
that initial assumption is so wrong so
today we're entering the danger zone of
international politics to see whether or
not we can piece together the faceless
enemy of top gun maverick using context
clues geographic hints and easter eggs
that are sprinkled throughout the film
share tom cruise you can sneak past an
onslaught of surface-to-air missiles
that you can't sneak past matpat who are
maverick rooster and their wingmen
really up against in the new movie strap
in friends and check your six we're
going in as i just mentioned despite the
enemy being kept anonymous throughout
the new movie we actually learn a lot
about him over the course of the film
here's the setup a uranium enrichment
facility in an unnamed foreign territory
is very close to achieving nuclear
weapons and the navy does not want this
country to have nukes to help bring down
the facility the navy calls in maverick
tom cruise's cocky all-star pilot to
teach a team of elite graduates how to
accomplish this dangerous bombing
mission the mission involves a low
altitude run through a treacherous
canyon defended by missiles followed by
a one in a million shot at a distant
target and then a daring escape that'll
almost certainly involve aerial
dogfights against at least three fifth
generation enemy fighters basically this
thing is like the death star trench run
from star wars but with actual fighter
jets instead of spacecraft during the
finale for both maximum closure and
maximum nostalgia when both maverick and
rooster son of maverick's dead best
friend goose are shot down behind enemy
lines they're forced to fight their way
home in a stolen vintage f-14 tomcat
just like the team flew back in the
original in 1986. the whole thing ends
with the crew overcoming the odds and
their own personal daddy issues all with
minimal amounts of sweat so hug it out
there gentlemen you deserve it first off
let's look at the mission parameters
themselves we're told that the unnamed
hostile actor at the center of the
bombing raid is a rogue nation in the
year 2022. now funny enough the state
department officially stopped using that
term decades ago instead replacing it
with a much less exciting label states
of concern some tells me though this
wasn't a mistake on the part of the
writers but rather an intentional
reference to a certain other tom cruise
franchise we're also told that this
nation's work to enrich uranium is in
violation of a number of treaties and
that the enrichment facility needs to be
destroyed before they can get the
uranium to the point where they can
create nuclear weapons which means that
they do not currently have nukes what
they do have though is a multi-tiered
air and ground arsenal that includes
older refurbished aircraft like the f-14
a defense array of soviet-era s-125
surface-to-air missiles and new fifth
generation fighters specifically that's
a russian sukhoi su-57 with its real
actual nato reporting name being get
this felon we also know from digital
maps and training simulations that we
see in the movie that the terrain is
mountainous with at least one river and
a large bridge and that it's within
flying range of the ocean since the navy
fighters are able to disembark directly
from an aircraft carrier and while some
convenient cloud cover prevents us from
seeing what the coastline of the country
actually looks like we definitely get a
very clear look at the very real terrain
thanks to our heroes flying low and
having to hoof it on foot after getting
shot down here we see that at least part
of the region is snowy meaning that
we're either at a high altitude or that
it's seasonally cold looking at the
plant life in the region we can see
large pine and fir trees in reality
that's because these scenes were mainly
shot in washington state's cascade
mountains so you know part of the
country that we're ultimately looking
for is going to have some vibes similar
to the pacific northwest like i said
that is actually a surprising amount of
detail to work with so to start let's
explore the term rogue nation or rogue
state currently there are only eight
countries that are officially
categorized as rogue states by the us
government with the ninth that kind of
makes it on the list by default on the
list we have venezuela syria russia
nicaragua north korea iran cuba and
belarus with the ninth country being
afghanistan since its current government
is controlled by the taliban who aren't
recognized as legitimate by the us also
just to mention it for completionist's
sake i'm gonna include china as a
candidate here on the list for the movie
only because while officially on
friendly terms with the us the two
countries do have significant
geopolitical disagreements so already
we've narrowed the list of possible
contenders down from 195 countries in
the world to only 10 and we can actually
knock off a few more quickly based on
the mission parameters right off the bat
it can't be china north korea or russia
since all those countries already have
themselves nuclear weapons so then
building a new enrichment facility
wouldn't be as big of a deal or as top
of a secret as we see the enemy nation
and maverick making of it so now we're
down to seven from here we're gonna have
to dig a bit deeper into the details for
each candidate afghanistan certainly
looks the part it has mountainous
territory snow forests defensible
canyons just like we see in the movie
afghanistan is also crawling with
soviet-era weaponry and let's just say
that the current leadership would be
very unlikely to decline having their
own uranium enrichment facility all of
it seems to fit except there's just one
problem afghanistan is landlocked
approximately 280 miles away from the
nearest coast in the arabian sea so
that's gonna strain the logistical
possibility of the film's finale the no
coastline issue also eliminates belarus
despite its russian-aligned leader
definitely being on america's naughty
list these days another point against
belarus though its climate is largely in
line with what we see in the film its
geography is actually too flat for the
mountains that we see in the film on the
flip side is cuba which we're gonna
eliminate for the exact opposite problem
well it's absolutely close enough to
ocean water cuba is definitely not our
culprit it's a tropical island and
therefore doesn't have any snow this is
also going to eliminate nicaragua from
the list since it doesn't snow there
either we can also eliminate venezuela
though it snows a little up in the
highest elevations of the andes
mountains it definitely doesn't have a
tree canopy that looks anything like we
see in maverick the andes are a tropical
montane cloud forest with a flora
coverage primarily of conifer trees
which would not match the cascade
mountain aesthetic shooting location at
all and just like that our roster has
suddenly narrowed from 195
to only two syria and iran and we did
that in what like a page page and a half
two longish paragraphs gotta be like a
new record here this thing is
practically a youtube short we're being
so efficient anyway syria and iran these
two countries are actually pretty close
together geographically both would be
accessible from the persian gulf using
the f-18 hornet fighter jets that we see
our heroes flying in maverick and while
this might be a surprise given that
middle eastern countries often are
stereotyped as giant deserts they both
also have mountainous regions where snow
and vegetation could reasonably pass as
the pacific northwest both countries
have also been either suspected or
accused of developing nuclear programs
outside of international agreements in
the past so at least for the purposes of
the fictitious story of this movie that
part is also going to check out of the
pair syria seems like it's the most
logical answer in fact this whole
movie's plot may just be based on a real
operation that actually happened there
you see syria has already attempted to
enrich uranium in the recent past
starting a secret project at a reactor
in a remote valley back in 2007.
secret enrichment program in a remote
valley you say someone call in tom
cruise the facility was eventually blown
up by israeli fighter jets in a mission
that was only acknowledged a decade
later as operation outside the box gotta
love how militaries worldwide name their
top secret operations anyway the
circumstances of that event are so
similar to the mission in maverick i
wouldn't be surprised if at least part
of the plot's inspiration originated
there it's also worth noting that the
syrian government has had far more
active military engagements recently its
president is also known for buying
russian arms and military support so if
anyone's gonna have the russian-built
fifth generation fighters like we see in
the movie syria is one where it's gonna
make a lot of sense in fact russia has
already tested their fifth generation
fighters over syria multiple times in
the past syria also has the much older
sukhoi su-22 and 24 models as part of
their active air force so really it
seems like syria is the obvious slam
dunk here they've got the planes they've
got the geography they've got the
history of trying to enrich the uranium
seems like the only thing they don't
have are the f-14s they certainly have a
fair number of older planes in their air
force but they're missing that one
crucial model and it's a model that we
have to have to get that big nostalgic
punch in the final act of the movie how
else are two testosterone-charged men
supposed to overcome their beef so that
just leaves us with one iran and they
check pretty much all of our boxes
though they haven't had as many recent
active military entanglements they do
have a similar history of buying up
russian aircraft and weaponry like syria
they do have a sukhoi su-24 in their air
force's active roster and a much older
model but it shows a history of
purchasing russian supplies and recently
it seems that they've expressed interest
in purchasing russia's newest fifth
generation fighters additionally iran
has similar terrain and geography to
what we see in the film they're close
enough to an ocean that a u.s carrier
could launch missiles and jet fighters
into it for a mission and they've had
nuclear ambitions in the recent past see
though iran was supposed to denuclearize
thanks to a deal made during the obama
administration the program has entered
much more unknown territory after more
recent presidencies withdrew the us from
the agreement of more immediate
importance to the events of maverick
though iran is one of the only modern
military powers still operating an
active fleet of f-14 tomcats that means
it's just about the only plausible
candidate on the list that could also
allow for the nostalgic climax with tom
cruise and rooster flying the original
top gun jet there you have it loyal
theorists by process of elimination the
most likely candidate for the unnamed
enemy and top gun maverick is iran it's
the only place that has the right mix of
politics military resources geographic
location topographical details
environmental terrain and specific use
of weapons technology to make the events
of the film play out exactly like we see
him do on screen or you know what maybe
i'm completely wrong maybe the big twist
of this whole thing is that really this
movie was a secret crossover just look
at the enemies logo on the fighter jets
looks an awful lot like this symbol the
symbol of arstotzka from the game papers
please maybe the real theory here is
that top gun maverick was actually the
most successful video game movie of all
time but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and
cuts
[Music]